What is Amniotic Fluid Made Of?
Essential for the development of a healthy
baby, amniotic fluid is a complex liquid that
nourishes, facilitates growth, cushions and
protects the growing fetus.
Amniotic fluid begins to form almost as soon
as implantation of the egg occurs.
Growing in volume at a rate faster than the
embryo at first, the initial water in the
fluid comes from the mother’s blood plasma.
As development progresses, so does the amount
of fluid: at 10 weeks, there should be approximately
25 ml of fluid, while at 20 weeks, there should
be about 400 ml (about 14 ounces).
Through the first five months, the amniotic
fluid’s composition will be similar to the
fetus’ plasma, due in no small part to the
fact that the baby has yet to develop an outer
layer of skin filled with keratin (the protein
found in the outer skin layer that makes it
waterproof).
Keratinization (which begins at about 20 weeks
and is complete by 25 weeks) is a key moment
in the production of amniotic fluid, as after
it occurs, at 28 weeks, the amount of amniotic
fluid peaks and plateaus at about 800 ml.
From this point, it will only decline until
it falls back down to about 400 ml at 42 weeks.
Also after keratinization, the composition
of the fluid will be different, and will include
fetal urine, as well as secretions from its
mouth, nose and throat, lung fluid, etc.
Throughout gestation, fluid moves in and out
of the baby and between the baby and the mother,
allowing for changes in composition coinciding
with changes in development.
During the latter half of a pregnancy, urea
and creatinine increase, while sodium and
chloride will decrease.
One of amniotic fluid’s primary purposes
is to nourish the fetus, and to do so, it
is filled with proteins, carbohydrates, lipids,
peptides, taurine, glutamine, lactate, pyruvate,
electrolytes, hormones and enzymes, and these
circulate from the fluid into the fetus through
the skin, and later in development are swallowed
by the fetus and excreted by him or her.
Epidermal growth factor (EGF) and transforming
growth factor alpha (TGF-a) and beta-1 (TGF-b1)
are also found in the fluid, as are insulin-like
growth factor I (IGF-I), erythropoietin (EPO)
and granulocyte colony-stimulating factor
(G-CSF).
Of course, the fluid is also important in
cushioning and protecting the growing fetus,
and for the latter, it is filled with antimicrobial
peptides and enzymes to fight against potentially
invading viruses and bacteria.
In addition, because the baby breathes in
the fluid, it is critical in helping the fetus’
lungs to develop.
Likewise, because the baby also swallows the
fluid, it is key to helping its digestive
system to mature.
An average human fetus toward the end of a
full term can consume as much as 15 ounces
of fluid in a single day.
The mechanical aspects of the fluid are also
important to the growth of bones and muscles,
as the fluid allows the baby to easily move
around, which helps it both develop and strengthen.
Furthermore, the simple act of lubricating
all parts of the baby helps keep the different
developing parts of the fetus from growing
together (think webbed toes).
From all this, you may not be surprised to
learn that having too little or too much amniotic
fluid can be a problem.
Too little, called oligohydramnios, is usually
caused by a premature rupture of the membranes,
post-term pregnancy, poor fetal growth, certain
birth defects that affect the kidneys and
urinary tract and twin-to-twin transfusion
syndrome.
It is discovered either via ultrasound or
when fluid is leaking from the sac, and treatments
are limited to an amnioinfusion or, simply,
delivering the baby.
Oligohydramnios is the most worrisome if it
occurs during the first six months of pregnancy
and can cause birth defects, miscarriage,
stillbirth and premature birth.
If it happens during the last trimester, slow
fetal growth may occur, and a ceasarean birth
may be required.
On the other hand, too much amniotic fluid,
called hydramnios, is caused by maternal diabetes,
gastrointestinal abnormalities in the fetus,
fetal swallowing problems, twin-to-twin transfusion
syndrome, a fetal infection and heart failure.
The symptoms of hydramnios include a rapidly
growing uterus, maternal discomfort and even
contractions.
Treatments include medications, amnioreduction
via amniocentesis and delivery.
While mild hydramnios may cause no problems,
severe hydramnios can result in defects of
the brain and spinal column and blockages
of the digestive system.